Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dansScienceClic, les trous de ver.
Selon la théorie de la relativité générale,
notre Univers est une hypersurface, à quatredimensions,
dans laquelle évoluent les astres, et tous les objets,
c’est l’espace-temps.
Cet espace-temps n'est pas rigide,
il possède une certaine géométrie
qui va sedéformer sous la présence de masse, et d'énergie,
Il peut se courber.
C’est cette courburequi est
notamment la base de la gravitation.
Un trou noir est un objet
dont toute lamasse est concentrée en un seul point,
Qu’on appelle la singularité.
De par sa masse,le trou noir
déforme l’espace-temps autour de lui.
A partir d’une certaine proximité,
l’espace-temps est tellement courbé,
que tous les objets,
et même la lumière, ne peuvent plus s’en échapper.
Un trou noir possède ainsi un horizon, une sphère,
à l’intérieur de laquelle la courbure spatio-temporelle devient tellement forte
qu’il est impossible de revenir en arrière.
Pour mieux visualiser le trou noir,
on peutreprésenter sa géométrie
En effectuant ce qu’on appelle
en mathématiques un "plongement".
Leplongement va nous fournir une figure
géométrique, qui reproduit fidèlement les propriétés
decourbure de l’espace autour du trou noir.
Après calcul, on peut observer
que l’espaceautour du trou noir
se comporte à la façon d’un entonnoir.
A grande distance, il est relativement
plat, c’est à dire très peu courbé.
Mais plus on se rapproche
de l’horizon,plusla courbure s’intensifie.
Étonnamment, à première vue, on a l’impression
quela structure même de l’univers contient un trou.
L’existence de ce trou peut paraître étrange,
Onpeut se demander ce qui se passerait par exemple,
si un vaisseau spatial en atteignait la bordure.
L’Univers s’arrête-t-il au niveau du trou ?
Pour répondre à cette question,
il est nécessairede comprendre une subtilité mathématique.
Notre Univers, et en particulier
l’espace-temps, possèdequatre dimensions.
Trois dimensions d’espace, et une dimension de temps.
Mais en représentantla géométrie de l’espace,
on s’est affranchi de deux de ces dimensions.
D’une part, l’horizon dutrou noir est censé être une sphère,
mais ici, pour pouvoir représenter l’espace-temps,
on a supprimé une dimension d’espace,
on s’est placé dans un plan,
et l’horizon apparaît donc comme un cercle.
D’autre part, on n’a représenté que la
courbure de l’espace,mais pas le temps.
On a délibérément retiré la dimension
temporelle de notre diagramme.
En conséquence, le diagramme est figé,
Il ne représente la courbure de l’espace
qu’à un seul et unique instant dans le temps.
Lorsqu’il tombe vers le trou noir, notre
vaisseau spatial avance dans le temps.
En effet, si le temps ne s’écoulait
pas, le vaisseau serait figé,
Il ne pourrait pas progresser.
Ainsi,lorsqu’on s’intéresse
à la chute du vaisseau au cours du temps
Il est nécessairede faire également évoluer notre plongement,
pour que celui-ci représente bel et bienla courbure de l’espace
A l’instant vécupar le vaisseau.
Et lorsqu’on fait évoluer
lediagramme de cette façon, on observe que le trou
se referme très rapidement sur lui-même.
Lorsqu’il atteint l’horizon du trou noir,
le vaisseau est en mesure de le traverser,
et ilcontinue sa chute vers la singularité centrale.
Mathématiquement, on peut
démontrerque quelque soit l’observateur,
et même pour un rayon lumineux,
cette sortede trou dans l’Univers va toujours se refermer
suffisamment vite de sorte à être absolumentinatteignable.
Selon la relativité générale,
la structure de l’espace peut admettre un teltrou,
mais celui-ci est nécessairement
destiné à se refermer sur lui-même extrêmement vite,
de sorte qu’il est impossible de l’atteindre.
L’univers ne possède donc pas réellement de trous,
Mais du point de vue de notre imagination,
et de l’élégance mathématique,
cette réponsen’est pourtant pas très satisfaisante.
Même s’il se referme très vite, le trou
semblebel et bien exister pendant un bref instant,
ce qui peut paraître bizarre.
Enl'occurrence, on a l’impression
qu’il manque quelque chose à notre théorie,
Que celle-cine décrit pas parfaitement la situation.
Avec les mathématiques, il est possible,
àl’intérieur des équations, de dupliquer
La géométrie de l’espace,
d’en faire une copie, maisen sens inverse.
Dans cette version inversée,
la copie du trou noir se comporte différemment,
Au lieu de tout absorber
inexorablement,elle recrache tous les objets,
sans que rien,même la lumière, ne puisse jamais y rentrer.
C’est ce qu’on appelle un trou blanc,
ou parfoisune fontaine blanche.
Maintenant que l’on dispose de cette copie de l’espace-temps,
On va pouvoirvenir la coller en dessous de notre trou initial.
Cette manoeuvre mathématique est quelque peuartificielle,
Et aucune observation physique ne permet de la justifier.
Il s’agit d’une extensionmathématique, qui est principalement
motivée parla symétrie des équations.
D’un point devue des mathématiques,
on forme ainsi une structure beaucoup plus satisfaisante,
quiprend la forme d’un tube, et non plus d’un simple trou.
C’est ce genre de structure,
enforme de tube, qu’on appelle un trou de ver.
Si une telle structure existe, le trou de
ver doit nécessairement relier deux parties d’espace-temps.
Peut-être qu’il relie deux universindépendants,
mais peut-être aussi qu’il relie
deux endroits différents à l’intérieur d’un seulet même univers.
Il formerait ainsi un raccourci
géométrique entre ces deux régions,
Que la lumièreou les objets pourraient peut-être emprunter
Pour se rendre plus rapidement d’un endroit à l’autre.
En laissant libre cours à notre imagination,
on peut très vite s’imaginer un futur
danslequel des vaisseaux spatiaux
traverseraient de tels raccourcis dans l’espace-temps
pour voyager de galaxie en galaxie.
Mais ce trou de ver en question,
Qui estformé d’un trou noir et d’un trou blanc,
qu’on surnomme également
le “pont d’Einstein-Rosen”,ne peut pas être traversé.
En effet, commeon l’a vu précédemment,
sa structure de tube, qui est l’extension du trou,
se refermeextrêmement rapidement sur elle-même,
étranglant tout observateur qui s’y aventure.
Decette façon, il est impossible de le traverser,
et on peut uniquement se dirigervers la singularité du trou noir.
Fort heureusement pour notre curiosité,
il existe cependant d’autres géométries
de trous de vers, qui sont mathématiquement
acceptables selon la relativité générale,
et dont les propriétés sont plus avantageuses.
Tout d’abord, si un trou noir est en rotation surlui-même,
Ou qu’il possède une charge électrique,
Il pourrait être possible, cette fois-ci, de
traverser le trou de ver qui lui est associé,
Car, dans ce cas,
la singularitéau centre n’est plus un point,
Mais un anneau,
ce qui génère autour d'elle un nouvel horizon
A travers lequel il estpossible de passer.
Cela dit, ce trou de ver
ne serait traversable que dans un seul sens,
car, après en être sorti, on ne peut
pas rentrer dans le trou blanc.
Les physiciens théoriciens ont donc mis au
point des géométries plus sophistiquées,
avec des propriétés plus intéressantes,
qui s’affranchissent des trous noirs et des trous blancs,
pour être plus propicesà un réel voyage.
Ces trous de vers purement mathématiques
sont conçus pour obéirà certaines conditions de faisabilité.
Premièrement, on veut
que notre trou dever soit traversable dans les deux sens.
Contrairement au pont d’Einstein-Rosen,
il doit donc être dépourvu de toute formed’horizon,
de sorte que chaque endroit soitfranchissable
dans un sens, comme dans l’autre.
Deuxièmement,
le trou de ver doit être stable dansle temps.
En effet, s’il se referme sur lui-même, ou qu’il est instable,
il pourrait êtrerisqué de l’exploiter pour des voyages.
Troisièmement,
pour pouvoir le traversersans encombre,
le tube qui forme le trou de ver doit être suffisamment large,
sinon ilserait tout simplement impossible d’y entrer.
Quatrièmement,
le temps nécessaire à traverserle trou de ver
doit être raisonnable,par exemple quelques années.
En effet, si levoyage prend plusieurs milliards d’années,
le trou de ver n’a pas de grande utilité.
Et pour finir,
les forces degravité qui sont générées par
sa géométrie ne doivent pas être trop prononcées,
de sorte à ne pas trop abîmer ou étirer la
structure du vaisseau qui le traverserait.
Mathématiquement, il existe de telles géométriesqui
sont bel et bien acceptées par la théoriede la relativité générale.
L’un des exemples lesplus simples,
est le trou de ver de Morris-Thorne.
Le trou de ver de Morris-Thorne
possède de nombreuses propriétéstrès intéressantes.
Il ne comportepas d’horizons, pas de singularités,
il est parfaitement stable dans le temps,
et contrairement au pont d’Einstein-Rosen,
il ne va pas se refermer au moment où on letraverse.
Ce trou de ver est particulièrement
intéressant du fait qu’il est purementgéométrique,
c’est à dire que sa structure
bien particulière lui permet de ne pas générerde gravité.
Ainsi, il est possible de rester
immobile à côté d’un tel trou de ver,
sans quecelui-ci ne nous attire ou ne nous repousse.
Lorsqu’on essaie de le franchir,
notre vaisseauva se déplacer le long d’une géodésique,
c’est à dire une ligne droite
à l’intérieur del'espace-temps courbé.
Les géodésiques du troude ver
de Morris-Thorne sont bien particulières.
Certaines trajectoires entrent
dans le trou dever, font quelques tours à l’intérieur,
maisfinissent par ressortir du tube,
du même côté parlequel elles sont entrées.
Pour traverser ce troude ver,
étant donné qu’il ne génère pas de gravitépour nous attirer,
il est donc nécessaire de bien
diriger son vaisseau vers l’intérieur du trou.
En apparence, comme pour un trou noir, les
rayons lumineux sont déviés par cette géométrie,
le trou de ver agit donc comme unelentille,
qui déforme l’image des étoiles environnantes.
Mais du fait que lesrayons
lumineux peuvent également le traverser,
on peut aussi y observer
les astresqui se trouvent de l’autre côté,
et donc visualiser à l’avance la zone de
l’univers vers laquelle il nous relie.
Le trou de ver de Morris-Thorne
est particulièrement élégant,
et il semble remplir toutes les conditions
nécessaires à la possibilité d’un voyageintergalactique.
Mais tout n’est pas si simple,
son existence nécessite en effet de le stabiliser,
en plaçant autour de lui une sphère d’énergienégative.
Cette énergie négative permet
de s’opposer à la tension de l’espace-temps,
quiforce continuellement les structures
de ce type às’étrangler sur elles-mêmes,
comme on l’a vu avecle pont d’Einstein-Rosen.
Mais malheureusement,
dans le cadre de la relativité générale,
on peutdémontrer mathématiquement
qu'une telle énergie négative n’est pas possible
et donc que lestrous de ver stables ne peuvent pas exister.
Aussi décevant que cela puisse paraître,
les trous de vers sont
donc impossibles du point de vue de la relativité générale,
car leur existence en tant que structuresstables
nécessite de l’énergie négative sur unelongue durée,
ce qui, n’est mathématiquementpas possible.
Ce principe très fort estappelé
le théorème de censure topologique.
Il nous indique que toute structure de typetrou de ver
va se censurer automatiquement,
c’est à dire se refermer sur elle-même
pourtout observateur qui tente de l’atteindre.
Mais ces conclusions très définitives
sont baséessur la relativité générale.
Or on sait aujourd’hui que cette théorie n’est pas parfaite.
Enparticulier, elle ne prend pas forcément en compte
certains phénomènes quantiques,
qui se produisentaux échelles microscopiques.
A ces échelles, d’autres théories entrent en jeu,
et notammentla théorie quantique des champs.
Selon cette théorie
qui décrit les particules à l’échellequantique,
le vide possède une certaine énergie,
qui est sans cesse agitée de fluctuations.
Ces fluctuations sont appelées des particules virtuelles,
et on peut les assimiler à desparticules ordinaires
qui apparaîtraient puis disparaitraient très rapidement.
Toutesces particules virtuelles génèrent
une sorte de pression résiduelle dans l’espace,
quiva dans certaines configurations agir
de façon analogue à une énergie négative.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’effet Casimir.
Ainsi, même si la relativité générale,
à elle seule, semble repousser l’idée de trous de vers stables,
les phénomènes dela physique quantique
pourraient peut être apporter une solution.
Certainsscientifiques, entrevoient déjà des parallèles
entre les trous de vers
et lephénomène de l’intrication quantique.
De plus, certaines théories encore spéculatives,
et notamment la théorie des cordes,
offrent de nouvelles perspectives d’approche
pour l’existence de trous de vers naturels,
qui se seraient formés juste après le Big Bang,
et qui auraient été étirés
après leur créationpar l’expansion de l’Univers.
En théoriedes cordes, de tels trous de vers
seraientstabilisés par des cordes cosmiques,
qui sontdes objets pour l’instant purement hypothétiques.
Pour finir, si l’existence des trous
de vers parvenait à être prouvée,
elle soulèverait la question du voyage dans letemps.
En effet, la théorie de la relativité,
qui travaille non pas sur l’espace,
mais surl’espace-temps,
n’empêche pas un tel objet de relier deux instants différents.
Pour lemoment on ne sait toujours pas
si le voyage dans le passé est possible,
mais peut être quetelles structures le rendraient envisageable.
Cela dit, pour des raisons de cohérence,
un trou de ver ne pourrait certainement pas permettre de revenir  plus loin dans lepassé que l'instant même de sa création.
Les trous de vers
sont des objets mathématiquesfascinants,
dont l’étude, bien que complètement spéculative,
nous permet de renforcer nos théories
actuelles, en les mettant constamment à l’épreuve,
et en tentant perpétuellement de repousserleurs limites.
Bien que la possibilité de trous de vers
traversables ne soit toujourspas écartée,
pour le moment, les seules personnes à traverser
des trous de vers sont lesphysiciens théoriciens,
munis de leurs équations.